they set sail obeying orders and ended
up behind bars in Russia 22 Ukrainian
soldiers and two members of the
country's security services they were
captured by the Russian Navy which
opened fire on their three boats here in
the Kerch Strait nine months ago Russia
says they legally entered its waters
near the Crimean Peninsula seized by
Russia from Ukraine in 2014 a British
show uh Sheila - the Russian let me draw
your attention to the fact that they
trespassed in Russian territorial waters
which were Russian even before Crimea
joined the Russian Federation that is in
the place where Russian territorial
waters have always been the Kerch Strait
gives the only access to Ukrainian ports
in the Sea of Azov but it's now largely
under Russian control and tensions in
the region are high in July this Russian
tanker was seized by the Ukrainians who
said it had been involved in the capture
of their sailors the Russian crew were
later released President Putin had been
pressured by the European Union and the
United States to release the sailors an
international tribunal had also ordered
Russia to immediately release the man
and their ships the Kremlin refused
several of the men were reportedly moved
from labor camps in different parts of
Russia to a single jail in Moscow ahead
of their exchange with Russians being
held in Ukrainian prisons Russia seized
control of Crimea five years ago after
sending in troops it's also still
backing separatists in a war with
Ukrainian forces in eastern Ukraine more
than 10,000 people have been killed
since the fighting began five years ago
Ukraine's new president Vladimir's RN
ski says he wants to revive peace
negotiations with Russia
he's been courting European leaders
recently Putin and zalenski have already
spoken by phone the prisoner exchange
could be an important tentative step
towards further dialogue Andrew Simmons
al Jazeera